what's going on reject nation Greg got
here charmita Bhattacharya with us today
you might have seen around the javi
Kuwait channel and she's here today sure
meat that you like comedy right sketches
town sugar you like sketches right well
today we're gonna watch a sketch I was
requested by Angie Terpening over at
patreon and one of our patreon perks is
that whatever you request we must
definitely do today from rocketjump a
fantastic youtube channel please go
subscribe to these guys immediately even
if you haven't seen their videos do
yourself a favor and subscribe in that
the floor is lava she just explained to
me what that game is the floor is lava
that's where you kidnapped someone and
then you heat up the floor and you have
them stand there until the floor gets so
hot they get third-degree burns that
they finally reveal the information to
you and then you shoot them in the head
afterwards you can also go to the amount
of your board mm-hmm
good yes and good yes and
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
dresser
[Laughter]
you can back it up
[Laughter]
[Music]
how do you get into that bedroom
[Music]
that's kind of scary
[Music]
No
oh no I was the couch not melted
[Music]
I
[Music]
it's gonna go in there there's no time
come on you're leaving me
and if you keep a zumba more often you
would we listen I did it we're all
scared okay in the only way we're gonna
get through this is this friends
together what do you say yep it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh god Erica
yeah I got you bro
[Music]
but if he applies pressure on it
is it the clients
[Music]
nice
[Music]
if this was a real sci-fi movie we'd be
questioning everything
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
your way
[Music]
[Music]
be careful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we just want to hang out with
[Music]
yeah because it's a great spoof on any
type of gin generic sighs my lava I like
that they like made it so real cough
course because that you know you burn to
the world of the game yeah but then they
did take you back out of at the end so
cuz you know how we were like how is he
floaty yeah it's like if you would think
about the world that they were in which
is technically they're imagining they're
yeah that person is still there yes can
use them as like this yeah lever to get
that and the way it's written is like
twelve-year-old boys who were playing
pretend if the floor was really love it
was rising I mean I loved all the
moments of when they're not getting
along as roommates and they're fighting
and then the one forensic oh yeah hey
we're all scared yeah I was thinking
this must have been the most fun thing
for them to shoot because all this
after-effects that they include later
I'm sure it was such a total blast to be
shooting in your own house and to be
putting some like this together with
your buddies man I'm very envious of
that
it'd be so crazy to make a short light
and the after-effects are not bad at all
I wasn't focusing on it which means they
did a good job yeah there's your like
like it's like the originals aren't like
it doesn't need to be like Hollywood
caliber but it's good enough for like a
YouTube video that's fantastic fantastic
job the writing of it was really well
done
I like the silly stupid action movie
disaster flick Arc of them not getting a
log and then respecting each other in
the end I'm glad you really enjoyed it
because I feel like it's more of like
dude humor in a way it's not like
raunchy dude humor but like this up bros
I think friendship is a friendship yeah
yeah better boy you're smarter than me
you get that woman brain it's bigger
guys rocketjump
i want to watch more of these guys
videos yeah you go subscribe to these
guys as soon as possible
you guys can subscribe to the rocket
jump you don't need to subscribe to us
but if you can if you want you know what
you should do you should check out
charmita bhattacharya x' Instagram and
Twitter mainly her Instagram because why
wouldn't you want to look at this on
social media along with the other girls
we look at yeah someone's gonna follow
you and just like all your clothes just
wait you'll see you'll see there's gonna
be that one guy can't wait to meet you